okay so this presentation we're going to
go over the endocrine system it's the
body system in the organs that are
responsible for releasing hormones let's
go ahead and get started so as I start
out on the endocrine system for now I
can just say that it helps to control
growth helps control our development and
our ability to respond to the
environment one thing you can see from
the picture is that the glands or the
organs are physically disconnected it's
not like this picture right here of the
digestive system where the esophagus
connects the stomach the stomach
connects to the small to the small
intestine it's not like that when we
look at the endocrine system the glands
are physically disconnected the glands
again are the major organs of the
endocrine system and glands ultimately
release hormones you've probably heard
of adrenaline the hormone called
adrenaline all those that's the hormone
released by the adrenal glands so all
glands release hormones and hormones are
the chemical signals that move
throughout our blood and so our
endocrine system releases hormones that
travel through our blood and ultimately
we'll end up at a target cell and the
hormones will direct that target cell to
respond in some kind of way depending on
the hormone so hormones ultimately
attach to a receptor that's found on a
target cell so here comes a hormone and
it just attached to this receptor see
all the triangular-shaped pieces fit
well this target cell now that it's
received the RIA hormone this target
cell will be stimulated to producing
various proteins that the cell needs so
we'll talk more about these in just a
moment but ultimately there are two
categories of hormones that I want to
mention steroid hormones and non steroid
hormones so the first category of
hormones I want to mention are called
steroid hormones and one thing I want to
mention it is that steroid hormones are
naturally produced by the body and in my
animation
we have a secreting cell secreting or
releasing steroid hormones into the
blood well let's follow those hormones
and see where they're going so when we
look at where are those steroid hormones
going in my animation you can see the
steroid hormone is bouncing off of a
non-target cell receptor the receptor
has a triangular shape to it and my
steroid hormone in the animation is more
round
so hormones don't match to every cell
hormones match to very specific cells
and in this case a steroid hormone is
going to attach to a receptor that's
actually located inside the cell so
steroid hormones can actually pass
through the phospholipid bilayer and
that's what you just see happening and
so the steroid head the steroid hormone
is attached to a receptor inside the
target cell the receptor and the steroid
hormone will go into the nucleus which
will start a bunch of chemical reactions
and allow this target cell it'll
stimulate the target cell to produce in
proteins that are needed by the body so
the other category of hormones are
called the non steroid hormones and just
like the steroid hormones non steroid
hormones are naturally produced by the
body and so the animation looks very
much the same so far I have a secreting
cell the word secreting means to release
I have a secreting cell here releasing
non steroid hormones into the blood well
let's see where they go so when we
follow the non steroid hormone we're
gonna see in a moment that it's gonna
attach to a receptor on the surface of
the target cell and here it comes so the
non steroid hormone has attached to a
receptor on the surface of the target
cell the non steroid hormone ever
actually does enter the cell what the
non steroid hormone does is that it
initiate a series of chemical reactions
for instance chemical reaction a will be
triggered which leads the chemical
reaction B which leads the chemical
reaction C and the products eventually
make their way into the nucleus
and the products will activate genes in
the nucleus which will cause the target
cell to send out and create a bunch of
proteins so the end result is kind of
the same in that non steroid hormones as
well as steroid hormones trigger the
target cells into making proteins so now
I want to start going over the major
glands of the endocrine system let's
start with the hypothalamus it's in the
brain and it releases hormones that will
stimulate the pituitary gland which is
just beneath it
so hormones of the hypothalamus will
travel through the blood to the
pituitary gland pituitary gland will
respond by releasing growth hormones
great example of how glands communicate
with other glands the hypothalamus also
helps to control body temperature you
know the picture shows the third a
thermostat on a wall at someone's house
set for 98.6 degrees you know that's
about the average body temperature and
if we get too hot or too cold the
hypothalamus will respond by releasing
hormones that will cause us to shiver
when were cold or sweat when we're too
hot so the hypothalamus is often kind of
called the thermostat of the body the
next gland I want to mention is a great
example of glands having more than one
job the pituitary gland for instance
regulates water levels in the blood if
our blood becomes too thick it's really
hard to pump so the pituitary gland will
release hormones to help control the
water content in our blood another
function of the pituitary gland will is
to relieve release growth hormones which
stimulate cell division and and causes
ourselves to just physically grow larger
and this is important as we hit the
puberty years of our life and then enter
into the adulthood years of our life so
that's about the hypothalamus will send
signals to the pituitary gland and the
pituitary gland will respond by
releasing growth hormones so the next
gland I want to mention is in our throat
area called the thyroid and like most
glands it has a role to play in many
processes one important press
is to help in in our metabolism and our
digestion of food you know there's a
couple hormones called the t3 hormone
and a t4 hormone and these hormones help
to control our metabolism and adjust our
rate of digestion one that's not
mentioned there's a hormone called
calcitonin which helps to lower calcium
that's in our blood if our calcium
levels get too high there's another
hormone called the parathyroid hormone
that helps to raise calcium in our blood
if our calcium level levels are too low
so again a great example of how a gland
has more than one purpose so as we work
our way down we come to the chest area
and there's a gland called the thymus
and the function of the thymus is to
release hormones to help white blood
cells mature to fight infection
specifically type of white blood cells
called t-cells and t-cells are very
important in the fighting off of
bacteria and virus viruses and pathogens
and the thymus will release a hormone
called thymosin and thymosin helps again
these t-cells to mature in order to
fight infection so the next gland i want
to mention is called the pancreas and i
hope you have a general idea that the
pancreas helps to control the glucose
levels or the sugar levels that are
found in our blood
you know after meals the amount of sugar
in our blood Rises and so the pancreas
will respond by releasing a hormone
called insulin to bring the level of
sugar or the level of glucose back to a
normal level well if there's ever times
when our blood sugar is too low then the
pancreas will respond by releasing a
hormone called glucagon
which were right raised raise the sugar
level back up to its normal level let's
look at these two in a little more
detail so when glucose levels are high
and that's what you see in the picture
right now a person's just had a meal and
their blood is full of G which stands
for glucose when when glucose levels are
high the pancreas will respond by
releasing
in the letter I in my animation the
insulin is attaching through these
little channels these little doorways
located on each cell and when the cell
channels receive the insulin watch what
happens next the insulin causes those
channels to open and I hope you can
predict what's gonna happen now that the
channels are open now that the channels
have opened the glucose simply diffuses
from a high concentration to a low
concentration into the cells that
reduces or lowers the amount of sugar
that's in the blood to a normal level so
the pancreas helped to control this by
releasing insulin what about the
opposite when glucose levels are too low
well here's a picture of our liver and
our liver will receive the hormone
called glucagon which comes from the
pancreas let's zoom on into this liver
here and here's a few cells of the liver
and the cells are receiving glucagon
which came from the pancreas these cells
of the liver they're gonna respond by
releasing stored amounts of glucose into
the blood that will bring the low level
back up to normal so gluco glucagon
brings levels up when they're too low
insulin bring his levels down when
they're too high okay so the next major
gland I want to mention are called the
adrenal glands and we have two of them
one on top of each kidney and the
adrenal glands help to control our
fight-or-flight response I'll say more
on that in just a moment well here is
our heart and here's the normal
heartbeat but in times of stress or in
times of a threat let's say a near car
accident or a suspicious character
walking towards you in a dark alley what
happens is the adrenal glands will
release a hormone called adrenaline are
also called epinephrine and this hormone
epinephrine will cause our faster
heartbeat will cause our heart to are
pulse to increase this causes our
fight-or-flight response it increases
our breathing makes us more alert
increases our blood pressure circulates
oxygen all throughout our body faster
and then we can either choose to fight
the threat or flight and by flight just
means run away it doesn't literally mean
take to the air and fly but in times of
threat or danger the adrenal glands will
release epinephrine to activate our
fight-or-flight response if we work our
way down we come to the male and female
gonads or sex organs let's look at the
female gonad first called the ovaries
women have two ovaries and the ovaries
will release hormones that will
influence sexual development so around
the age of puberty the pituitary gland
will send out hormones to the ovaries
the ovaries will respond and send out
hormones called estrogen and
progesterone these are the hormones that
will cause sexual development to occur
and so here's a list of some of the
features of are some of the effects
scuse me of estrogen development of the
ovaries starts the menstrual cycle
development of breasts you may have
heard of a condition called osteoporosis
where women age their bones become less
dense and a more likely to to break so
this is because women as they age
produce less and less and less estrogen
let's move on to the to the men next so
in men the male sex organ or the male
gonads are called testes and just like
in women around the age of puberty men
will receive hormones from the pituitary
gland the hormones from the pituitary
gland will cause the testes to release a
surge of testosterone which is the main
hormone released by the testes and
here's a list of some of the effects
that testosterone has in male sexual
development stimulates the production of
sperm cells
increases muscle mass leads to the
growth of facial hair so as as boys hit
puberty the testes will send send out
testosterone which will have some of
these effects that you see right here
and cause the development of sexual
features so before we're done with this
presentation I want to kind of show you
an example of how glands communicate
with other glands
for instance shivering three glands here
the hypothalamus pituitary and thyroid
the hypothalamus acts like the
thermostat and all sense that you are
cold and it will release a hormone down
of the pituitary gland I'm just gonna
call it hormone a for the sake of this
animation the pituitary gland will
receive hormone a and the pituitary
gland will respond by releasing hormone
B through the bloodstream down to the
thyroid gland the thyroid gland will
receive hormone B and then respond by
sending out hormone C all throughout the
body hormone C is the hormone that
actually causes a shivering this is just
a great example of what I mean by glands
communicating with other glands in order
to achieve a purpose shivering would
cause the person to generate heat to
warm to warm themselves so now that
we've kind of reached the end go ahead
and pause this video and try to label
what is abcdefgh
i'm gonna go over the answers in three
two one so now that you had a chance to
label these let's check your answers did
you call Part A the hypothalamus Part B
the pituitary gland Part C the thyroid
gland Part D
thymus Part II the adrenal glands Part F
the pancreas part G the ovaries and part
H the testes let's move on to the next
group of questions just like a moment
ago pause the video pause
the video and try to answer these 9
questions right here let's see how much
you've learned I'm gonna go over the
answers in three two one
so which gland releases growth hormone I
hope you said that's the pituitary gland
which one controls the water level in
the blood well that's the pituitary
gland as well which one increases our
alertness via the fight-or-flight
response well that's the adrenal glands
which one controls level of sugar in our
blood well that would be the pancreas
which one controls the level of calcium
in the blood that would be the thyroid
gland which one releases glucagon that
would be the pancreas again which one
helps to develop white blood cells well
that would be the thymus which one
releases the hormone called epinephrine
that would be the adrenal glands
epinephrine is also called a journal in
which one helps to control our
metabolism that would be the thyroid
gland well I hope you found this video
helpful you know here's a practice quiz
that you can try again at home pause the
video try to answer these questions if
you're in my biology class I'd be happy
to check your answers before school or
after school one day so go ahead and
pause the video good luck